the continued war against a 79 year old
infectious disease doctor who has worked
for six presidents continues I'm talking
about dr. Anthony foul she continues to
be the target of protesters remember a
couple of weeks ago a chant of fire foul
she broke out at one of these reopened
protests here's the audio and video
reminder of that
[Music]
[Applause]
well it's getting even worse they're
going from fire foul G now to signs that
say hang foul Chi hang foul Chi those
have started to pop pop up at protests
here's one from a Long Island New York
protests over the weekend which says
hang foul Chi hang gates open up all our
states very poetic very nice rhyming but
completely horrifying han gates of
course refers to Bill Gates who's
donating huge sums of his own money to
find a vaccine he's being regularly
attacked for it he's at the center of
multiple conspiracy theories arguing
that his intentions are actually
nefarious will there actually be any
accountability for the conspiracy
theorists that have spent months
spreading this nonsense because this is
a complete backslide from just basic
Enlightenment values now I want to be
careful because some of these
enlightened centrists and so-called
classical liberals they love to
fetishize talking about enlightenment
values and then they argue wildly that
the left on twitter is falling back from
enlightenment values by trying to do
things to prevent hate speech or
whatever we don't do that here okay I
don't know the last time I mentioned
enlightenment values this is not
something I've discussed that much
before but the anti science cesspool
that has become the coronavirus protests
it actually is a fight against basic
Enlightenment values of rationalist
philosophy a respect of science not
fetishizing science just a respect for
the scientific process and what it
provides us respect of the law
importantly so much of what we now take
for granted consider that
the terrorists don't have to attack us
anymore why would they we are destroying
ourselves from the inside as this battle
has been created between those who
understand and respect the scientific
process and who understand what is an
expert this is not about phony experts
but actually the difference between dr.
Anthony foutch II and some guy on the
internet with a blog right and those who
peddle conspiracies and mass gather
believe that they know better than
actual doctors this is not the crisis of
expertise which is something I've not
been shy about covering imagine the same
people rightly criticizing the signs and
the chance of death to America elsewhere
in the world they are the same ones who
chant fire foul Chi and hold up signs
that say hang foul Chi we're doing the
job of the terrorists for them I would
even go further when it comes to the
country being united against the common
enemy after 9/11 you Americans were by
and large briefly united very united it
didn't last that long because George W
Bush turned 9/11 into a war against Iraq
which had nothing to do with 9/11 at all
but there was a period there the end of
2001 when George W Bush went to the
rubble at Ground Zero his approval
ratings spiked I think it was 86 or even
90% in late 2001 and the country was
united this could have happened with
coronavirus I've said it before if on
March 5th Trump makes an FDR like speech
I'm not endorsing everything FDR did
okay so before you even start sending me
messages about that but an FDR like
speech where he speaks to the nation and
says we have difficult times ahead we do
the economics are going to be tough for
a little while but we must come together
we need stay at home from 50 governors
for 60 days you know maybe at the time
it would have been 30 and then it ends
up getting extended for 30 we're going
to come out on the other side we are
going to come out with few deaths we
will start to reopen and rebuild that
ship sailed but we
that also sailed the administration may
be presiding over a rational reaction
instead we've seen Donald Trump sort of
coyly support the protesters drawing a
line in the sand separating his view
from that of the scientists criticizing
everybody under the Sun about his own
mishandling from Obama to governor's to
Democrats whoever else while lying about
testing and everything else this doesn't
bode well for our future other countries
are realizing it I told you that there
laughter has mostly turned to horror and
pity at this point and I don't know how
we dig out of it my friends I really
don't if you love feeding your
intellectual curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time favorite apps called
blinka stinketh lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take thousands of popular
nonfiction books condense each one into
text or audio that you can get through
in just 15 minutes and you get all of
the important core ideas and information
from that book it's perfect if you don't
have enough time to do all the reading
you want to do or if you just want to
sample a book before you buy the entire
thing I recently read a brief history of
time of course by the great Stephen
Hawking this is a book that I have been
aware of for so long and other things
got in the way and it was fantastic to
check it out on blinken
blink East has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different nonfiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25%
off a subscription when you go to blink
is comm slash Pakman I've put the link
right underneath this video